>>Rich: Alright guys, thank you all for coming
and whoever is on VC thank you very much as
well.
I wanted to introduce you all to Dr. Jordan
Metzl.
He's here today to talk about his book "The
Athlete's Book of Home Remedies".
It's a terrific companion book for you guys
to make sure that you're not going to hurt
yourself like I did.
But he's going to be here today to talk about
all of his tricks and wizardry.
But I wanted to read you the dedication of
the book: "This book is dedicated to the millions
of athletes who wake up each morning at 5:30
with no fanfare and drag themselves out of
bed to keep fit.
Whatever your level or ability, may the information
in this book help you pursue your goals.
The most important thing you can do every
day is to keep moving forward."
So with that and without further introduction,
I want to introduce you to, and it is his
birthday so please be gentle on him, Dr. Jordan
Metzl.
[applause]
>>Jordan Metzl: Thanks.
Rich, thanks so much and it's great to see
everybody.
What a cool place.
I mean I feel like I'm not nearly cool enough
to be here.
But it's a pleasure to be here, to be down
to Google.
And I take care of a lot of you guys when
you hurt yourselves, up in my office and it's
a pleasure to down here and people conferenced
in out in California or wherever else you
are; the concept we're going to talk about
today is how to keep yourselves moving and
active and injury free.
So with that, I'm going to talk about this,
which is about a three year project I did
called "The Athlete's Book of Home Remedies"
the concept being that I want you to stay
active every day of your lives, starting now
for as long as you go.
And so we’ll talk about some of the themes
about that.
First thing is my website here, which is available,
for the last five years I've been doing the
medical column for Triathlete magazine.
Have pretty much one pagers on everything
related to running, endurance sports, anything,
shin splits, bonking, knee pain and those
are kind of free.
Also have a number of videos available on
my site, and there's a newsletter we put out
about four times a year.
We don't send your email to anybody, so no
spam, I promise.
Although guys' spam filter's pretty good so
I don't think it matters anyway.
But, certainly happy to have you guys sign
up.
There's a little registration tab.
I'd be happy to have ya.
Now, let's talk about what we're going to
talk about today.
And that is that exercise is very much medicine,
exercise keeps you going, exercise keeps you
young, it keeps you healthy.
And I want you to exercise every day.
Now, part of that is what do you do to make
that happen.
So, this is a picture of me at the Iron Man
several years ago.
I try and do one marathon and one Iron Man
a year.
For those of you who don't do Iron Man, you
don't have to do the Iron Man but if you're
interested, it's about a 2.4 mile swim, 112
mile bike ride and then a marathon.
And the first question is, why the hell would
you do that?
And the answer is that I deeply believe, number
one in goal setting and number two that basically
it is about meeting a goal.
Everyone needs something that pushes them
further than they think they should go.
And yes, fitness is a great thing to think
about in theory, but without a goal to do
that, it's very difficult to make yourself
take that next step.
So if you're goal is doing a big swim, doing
a ballroom dance competition, doing a 5k walk
in the park, whatever it is you wanna do,
the goal, you should set a goal for yourself.
So we're gonna talk about how you meet your
goal and I always have this, this is actually
my screen saver at work.
For example this morning, just to try and
get down I had about 15 patients in the office,
the last guy was like "dude, I've gotta go
to my thing, I'm late, come on" and started
yelling at my nurses.
Well, I don't get many of that in New York
but every once in a while I do and I then
I just look at this and my god, this was mile
17 of the run.
I'd already done the swim, the bike.
It was about 90 degrees, the sun was going
down and I was like I got 6 miles to go, I'm
gonna finish this thing and most importantly
my brother, Jamie, who I do these with, is
about a mile behind me and I'm gonna beat
that guy for the first time ever.
So I was pretty psyched about it, and so that
was my goal.
And so, I think the concept of this kind of
stuff is it gives you some place in your own
psyche, of like I'm having a tough day at
work, I'm having a tough time in my life and
yet this is a goal that I've been doing.
So, I deeply believe in that stuff.
So I think the concept was actually outlined
by the Roman poet, Juvenal, many thousands
of years ago.
Who talked about, 'It should be prayed that
in the mind, the mind be sound in a sound
body'.
So, copore, 'mens sana in corpore sano', sound
mind in a sound body.
They go together and here in this great environment
where you guys have created such an incredible
workspace to be creative and think about things,
I know in the place out in California there's
exercise facilities as part of what you do
out there.
You're all encouraged to be active and healthy,
and that's part of healthy mind.
And so I think these things go together very
much so I applaud you for the way you set
that up.
Let's look at the United States.
1985 in the United States, states reporting
10-14% obesity are in the darker blue, less
than 10% in the lighter.
But let's look at the United States 86, 87,
88, 89, 90, 91 now darker blue, 15-19% 92,
93, 94, 95, 96, 97 now greater than 20% 98,
99, 2000, 2001 greater than 25% obesity, 2002,
2003, 2004, 2005 now greater than 30% obesity
in the South East, 2006, 2007, 2008, 2009.
So basically, if you want to be thin, move
to Colorado.
That's the bottom line of this.
But as you can, we’ve had this march of
obesity across our country.
And this is an epidemic affecting everybody
and part of the problem with the way we set
up our health care in the United States, and
if you've been following this, we're going
to hear more about this in the next day or
two from the Supreme Court.
But we have a fundamental flaw in the way
we do business in the United States and that
is that our system which spends billions of
dollars, more than you know about 15-16% of
the GDP, estimated to go up 17-18%.
The problem is we treat disease.
So if you come in to see somebody with a heart
problem and you come in for your annual visit,
they put you on medication that's paid for
by your insurance company.
Then it goes on over time, and you need several
tests that’s paid for by your insurance,
you get a catheterization, that's paid for.
You eventually get open heart surgery, that's
paid for.
Your cardiac rehab, that's paid for.
Yet we spend almost no money paying to prevent
the problem before it happens.
And so we have this concept of incentivizing
disease treatment, we basically treat and
pay for disease, which is totally counter
intuitive.
Now we do some great things in America, like
companies like this, but we do have some problems
in the way we think about things.
In Germany, for example, if you have a cavity,
you have to go every six months to the dentist.
And if you have a cavity and you've been going
to the dentist every six months, the state
pays for your cavity.
If you have a cavity and you've not been going
to your annual six month checks up, you have
to pay for your own cavity.
And so the concept of incentivizing good health
behavior makes a ton of sense, yet we really
don't do it.
So since our government chooses to incentivize
things like home ownership or marriage or
kids, we incentivize different behaviors just
based on our tax hood.
We've not, we're not at the place yet where
we incentivize wellness, though I hope we
are at some point.
At this point the responsibility is all of
yours and all of yours out there.
And so you have to think about incentivizing
wellness because exercise is very much medicine.
So with that, I'm gonna show you why the case
for medicine is so significant with this great
video which I brought along for you guys particularly
because I know you'll appreciate how this
is done.
So let's look at this for a couple of minutes
to then get to the basis of what the book
is about.
Now, on this— there it is down there.
>>Dr. Mike Evans: Hi I'm Dr. Mike Evans and
welcome to this visual lecture I'm calling
"23 and a half hours"-
>>Jordan Metzl:--Any suggestions from back
there?
Alright hold on, we're gonna, I want this
to work so badly I'm gonna just minimize this.
We are having some technical issues, let's
watch this quickly on this thing.
[Pause]
>>Jordan Metzl: This will enlarge that?
>>Mike Evans: Hi I'm Dr. Mike Evans and welcome
to this visual lecture I'm calling "23 and
a half hours" So I have a big interest in
preventive medicine, you know which can mean
a lot of things from cancer screening to eating
more fiber to having a good social network,
and I mean that in the old sense of the word,
weighing less, drinking less, smoking less,
controlling your blood pressure, cholesterol
and so on and so forth.
So all these things are incredibly important,
I wouldn't want you to minimize your efforts
in any one category.
But I want to know what comes first, what
has the biggest impact, what has the biggest
return on investment.
[Cash register cha-ching]
>>Mike Evans: What makes the biggest difference
to your health?
So I did my research and I found an answer
at least for me and it's tricky, cause you
know all these things are sort of overlapping.
But I picked up this intervention because
of its breadth, it worked for so many different
health problems and that's what I found so
cool about it.
So just to kinda walk you through a quick
list, so this intervention in patients with
knee arthritis who receive one hour of treatment
three times a week reduce their rates of pain
and disability by 47%.
In older patients, it reduced progression
to dementia and Alzheimer's by around 50%.
For patients at high risk of diabetes and
coupled with other lifestyle interventions,
it reduced progression to frank diabetes by
58%.
Post-menopausal woman who had 4 hours a week
of the treatment had a 41% reduction in the
risk of hip fracture.
It reduced anxiety by 48%.
In a big meta-analysis, patients suffering
from depression 30% were relieved with low
dose and that bumped to 47% as we increased
the dose.
Following over 10,000 Harvard alumni for over
12 years, those that had the intervention
had a 23% lower risk of death than those who
didn't get the treatment.
It's the number one treatment of fatigue and
of course, the kind of outcome of choice there,
my favorite outcome is called quality of life
which is really all of the above.
[Ascending harp chord]
>>Mike Evans: And really about making your
life better.
And this treatment has been shown over and
over again to improve quality of life.
So, the question is what's the medicine and
what is 23 and a half hours?
So, the medicine was exercise, mostly walking.
[High chime]
>>Mike Evans: So not triathlons and let me
just put it a different way.
What I think I'm asking you to do is if you
think about your typical day so there's 24
hours and so you might spend most of your
day, you know this varies obviously, but you
know couch surfing -
[Boxing bell, computer keyboard keystrokes]
>>Mike Evans: -sitting at work, obviously
sleeping.
And what the evidence that I'm going to show
you kinda tells me is, the best thing you
can do for your health is to spend half an
hour of being active-
[Clock ticking]
>>Mike Evans: - maybe an hour and that if
you can do that you can realize all the benefits
I've described in the previous slides.
So let's just take a quick walk through some
of the literature.
So Steven Blair, he's a professor at the Arnold
School of Public Health at the University
of South Carolina, and he looked at this in
what's called the Aerobic Centre Longitudinal
Study, which followed over 50,000 men and
women over time and along the left side of
this graph is something called Attributable
Fractions which is kinda fancy word but it's
the estimate of number death in a population
that would have been avoided if that specific
risk factor had been erased.
So for example, turning a smoker into a non-smoker
or couch potato into a daily walker.
And along the bottom is the typical risk factors,
you can see that hyper-tension's incredibly
important and so on so forth, but the one
that was most, that kind of implied the most
risk was this sort of mysterious CRF, which
is Cardio Respiratory Fitness, which is really
low fitness.
So low fitness was the strongest predictor
of death.
And this important that most of the trials
we see, to be honest, are funded by Pharma
or other companies because they’ve got a
drug for hypertension or high cholesterol
or diabetes, we rarely see fitness thrown
into the mix and so it's nice to see a trial
that's not so siloed.
[Bicycle bell]
>>Jordan Metzl: The concepts of that, the
concepts of that I think are very helpful.
And I apologize if our, I may have to switch
back and forth here a couple times.
This was made, our hospital does not support
iBook yet, so unfortunately I had to design
on my old Dell.
Alright, so, we're gonna talk about what I
do now.
So hopefully I've convinced you that you gotta
move.
You gotta move every day and it's gonna be
helpful for you, it's gonna be helpful for
everybody around you, it's gonna be helpful
for your job, for your life for everything
that you do.
That you'll set some goals for yourselves
and make that happen.
Now let's talk about some of the pitfalls
of what you and so that you don’t get hurt
and then at the end I have promised I will
answer your injury questions.
So I'm sure we have plenty of runners and
people with plantar fasciitis and iliotibial
band syndrome etcetera.
here.
And you get to ask your questions as soon
as you're done listening to this stuff.
Alright, so what's my job?
Well my job is basically to make sure people
make good decisions about their fitness and
activity.
And I took this picture when I was out giving
a lecture in Wyoming last summer.
And so I was out in Jackson, Wyoming and I
saw some bright lights down the road.
And in fact there was a rodeo down there.
So I walked down there and I was like alright,
well I live in New York City but I can appreciate
a good rodeo probably as much as the next
guy.
And they had like the horses and the bulls
and all that stuff.
But the first thing, the next night I went
back there actually, I saw the demolition
derby the first night.
The second night they had one pen full of
kids and one pen full of sheep.
And my immediate thought was whatever combination
these two things are gonna combine is probably
not gonna be a good combination and in fact,
they would take one kid, put a bicycle helmet
on this kid and put him on top of, or her,
on top of a sheep, put a rope around the sheep,
open the gate and they had this Wyoming fan
favorite called mutton busting.
And no kids were harmed in the making of this
slide, but basically these poor kids are holding
on for dear life, between kinda 6 and 10 years
old and I immediately thought this is probably
not the best use of childhood fitness and
activity incentivization but yet everybody
was OK in this.
So my basic job is to help my patients be
active and help them understand when they're
doing something stupid.
And that I thought was probably something
a little bit stupid.
So how do you do that?
And so when I see somebody, we see a couple
different categories of injury, number one
is called an acute traumatic injury.
So I just got a call on Sunday, actually in
Iceland, from one of my patients who's getting
ready to be in the Olympic trials for gymnastics
who I've taken care of since she was quite
small.
And she landed and hurt her wrist so I was
worried about an acute injury like a fracture.
And so sometimes athletes need to know, be
they an Olympic athlete or somebody just getting
ready for whatever, you know, is this twist
of my knee that I did something I have to
worry about and how do I know?
And then, more commonly, about 90% of injuries
in sport medicine are what we call overuse
injuries.
So it's not one thing, but it's I've been
training for the marathon and my shins start
to hurt or my knee starts to hurt or I'm swimming
a lot and my shoulder hurts.
And how do you recognize when one of those
injuries is more serious?
And the answer is when pain changes your mechanic
of movement then I start to worry about those
kind of injuries.
So I'm gonna just make some comments on running,
I know here in New York City, this is certainly
is the most common.
Who's a runner here?
Let's see, we've got some, yeah I know and
I see a lot of you runners in my office.
And I'm sure out in California you have even
more runners.
And so I'm gonna talk about running in particularly
and some of the common things that we do and
I'm just gonna make a couple comments on running
and then we'll do some questions.
So what does it take to basically make you
a healthy runner?
And I'm gonna talk about gear, goals, injury
recognition and then lastly the important
part, which is prevention.
Prevention of running injuries so you can
keep moving.
So we've seen a lot recently about new trends
and fads in running gear.
And basically running is a great sport because
it's so inexpensive.
All you need to do is buy a pair of running
shoes.
Just curious, who's read the book "Born to
Run"?
Several in the room and so the concept of
this book is basically that less is more.
That by minimalizing or giving you a pair
of minimalist shoes or even this shoe on the
left here called a Newton, which tips you
forward a little bit, you can basically shorten
your stride and quicken your cadence.
And the answer is, the answer is that we think
that's probably true that having a higher
cadence and a shorter stride is much less
injury producing.
So what you should be doing is, you don’t
need to be buying minimalist shoes to do that,
just try shortening your stride and quickening
your cadence.
And certainly some shoes, such as like the
five fingered toes shoes can help make that
happen in the short term and I can answer
questions about how to know if you want to
do that or not.
But the overall concept is that a shortened
stride and a higher cadence is a good thing
to start thinking about for basically reducing
your risk of running injury.
What about goal setting?
Well I think goal setting is very helpful
and some of the problems we see from goal
setting are, well first of all not setting
goals at all.
So you definitely want to give yourself a
goal, whatever that is, a 5k race in the park.
You're lucky to be living in New York, I was
surprised how great the sports scene is in
New York.
For those in California, you know, they're
kinda spoiled because they can roll out of
bed and go do a big bike ride right out of
their door.
But we have an amazing sport resources here
in New York and probably the best running
club, the Road Runners club is probably the
best road running club in the world.
And just amazing races every weekend all over
the place and so it's been a great place to
do.
So you want to give yourself a goal and the
concepts of some of these charity programs
have convinced people you can train for the
marathon in three months and not get hurt.
And the answer is, that you know, unfortunately
that’s a huge part of my business even though
I try and teach people how not to come in
to see me.
But unfortunately these people say alright
I can do the marathon in three or four months
and the answer is that most people can't,
they get hurt because they don’t have enough
base training or experience.
And they’ve not gone through the building
phase of how it takes to build strength, bone
strength and muscle strength which we'll talk
about next.
Now what this guy taught us was that basically
not every body is built for everything and
some bodies are built better for some sports
than others.
And so if you have a running body, and for
girls, that's probably, or women, that's probably
about 5'2 and 90 pounds and for men, it's
about 5'6 and 120 pounds.
And if you don’t have that body, which basically
almost nobody does unless you're an amazing
Kenyan marathon runner, then you have to change
the way you train and change the way you think
about what you're gonna do.
Now, I think nothing I can tell you illustrates
this point as well as this video.
Which hopefully this will work.
This comes every year in japan, they have
the running of the Sumos and these guys are
built, these guys are built exceptionally
well for sumo wrestling but they're not built
very well for running.
So were going to see what this looks like,
hopefully.
Oh come on dude.
I gotta pull out the Sumo, I'm sorry.
[pause]
I won't pull up all but I gotta pull up the
running sumo.
Where is he?
Here he is.
So this is what the running sumo looks like
and the concept of the running sumo which
is pretty dramatic footage.
In Japan they do all kinds of interesting
stuff and having their sumo wrestlers run
down the street and video tape them, it's
one of the interesting things they do.
So this guy's really not built for running,
I'm sorry to tell you.
That’s not what you want to look like.
This guy's built great for sumo wrestling
but he's not built for running.
And so the concept of this is that not everybody
is built for every activity.
And basically Darwinian selection will kind
of tell us what you're built for.
So the further, the concept is, the further
you are from the idealized running body, the
more problems you're gonna have.
So the optimal training program, as far as
I'm concerned is a gradual build, some combination
of mileage and strength training and cardiovascular
training all the while.
You can't run every single day, nobody can.
And you wanna have a good time.
So let's talk now about injury, which is sort
of the thrust of what the book's about.
About recognizing and preventing injury and
so I want you to think about when an injury
is serious.
And the answer is if it's a baseball player,
if it's a runner, if it's a swimmer, a gymnast,
I ask my patients the same thing of any age
and I take care of people from kinda 8 year
old elite level gymnast to kind of 85 year
old lady that ran a marathon this year.
And the commonality of all these is they want
to be active and move.
And I want them to be active and move.
So, when an injury is serious, is it changes
your body's ability to do the sport regularly.
So if you could throw a baseball well but
then your elbow hurts cause you're throwing
the baseball improperly, I wanna see you.
If you're running and your shin is hurting
so much that you can't run properly, I wanna
see you.
So the mechanic of movement and the change
in the pattern of the mechanic of movement
is really the key issue that I see when an
injury happens.
So when it comes to running, I wanna talk
to you about three things; training and your
anatomy and the biomechanical factors that
go into injury and I'm gonna pull out a couple
of these videos to show you.
Now, the overall concept that I'm gonna kind
of impress upon you is call the kinetic chain
of the body.
And you so you kinda learn the song "the shin
bone is connected to the knee bone" and the
answer to that is true, that all the bones
are connected and we can't change your anatomy.
So if you're built a certain way because your
grandparents and their grandparents and their
grandparents all the way back, that’s who
you are.
I can't change how much cartilage you have
in your knee, I can't change if you have a
bulging disc in your back.
I can't change if you, you know, I can't change
those fixed anatomical factors.
What I very much can change in you and this
talk is a lot about empowering you to change
this, is you can change your kinetic chain,
and that is the muscular forces around those
bone and ligaments and tendons and muscles.
The muscles are the dynamic stabilizers, the
stronger your muscles, the strong your kinetic
chain.
So if you have plantar fasciitis or iliotibial
band syndrome, part of what we do with you
is get you started on a good functional strength
training program to strengthen that entire
chain and as that chain gets stronger, your
pain will go away and stay away.
So the answer is if your back hurts from a
bulging disc, don’t sit on your butt.
The answer is, start to work on strengthening.
And that's a lot about what this book is about
and what I'm gonna talk to you guys about.
So injuries happen, I'm just gonna push ahead,
I don’t care if I'm in pain, I'm not listening
to my body and all the sudden injuries happen.
And that’s often how injuries happen and
they can be overuse injuries in the tendon
such as this Achilles which as a big thickening
in the tendon like a partial tear.
MRI has been very very helpful to help us
diagnose these kind of injuries.
This is a big crack in the hip; this is somebody
with a stress fracture.
Just saw one of those this morning.
Somebody training for the Iron Man who got
a stress fracture in their hip.
Again, this is not an acute injury so you
won't know you have this.
You'll know that the more you do the more
pain you're having.
And the pain is changing how you move because
it hurts so much.
And that's when you gotta get it checked out.
So let's now talk about prevention which is
kind of the thrust of what this is gonna be
about.
So what are the ways you can prevent injury?
And first of all you wanna gradually build
your training.
We're gonna talk about running form.
And then lastly were gonna talk about preventive
strengthening and the role of preventive strengthening.
So there's, this graph kinda shows how much
stress you're putting on your body and the
frequency of how much you run.
And the concept here is there's what's called
the injury threshold.
No injury and injury.
And how do we take this line and push this
out so you can basically have more frequency
of running-
[Whip sound]
>>Jordan Metzl: We want that.
Alight, we want that line out there.
How do we keep ourselves here –
[Whip sound]
>>Jordan Metzl: -so that we push that threshold
out.
And the answer is, we're gonna change how
we run and we're gonna change how much strength
we have.
Those are the variables we can change.
So when you think about running, basically
you're never on two feet at a time except
for at the start and the end of the race.
And other than that, running is a series of
plyometric jumps from one leg to the other
and there is no exact right way to run.
But basically what I can tell you is that
I take care of a number of both triathletes
and runners and in my office, the triathletes
are hurt much less frequently, even though
they train about four times as much.
And the answer is because they do much more
functional training as part of what they do.
So in this, I'm not gonna pull these out and
play them, but basically I have somebody's
here who is stepping down off a box, let's
make sure these are not gonna work –
>>male voice: OK whenever you're ready step
down-
Alright, not gonna work.
So, she steps down off this small box, one
side versus the other, and the one leg that’s
not hurt, she steps down very evenly, and
the other side her knee is all wobbly when
she steps down and the answer is that as she
starts to wobble in that knee, the stability
of her hips and her knee joint is affected.
So she's not strong enough on this side she's
hurt with.
So if you're getting knee pain from running,
the answer is you have to strengthen the muscles
in the kinetic chain on that side of the body
particularly because what ends up happening
over time, is that this cartilage starts to
rub on this femur bone and you start to get
a lot of achiness underneath your knee called
runners knee which is pretty much the most
common knee problem that I see.
So how do we talk to people about improving
their running form?
And we talk about things such as running drills,
running uphill I love.
The concept of running uphill is you shorten
your stride and quicken your cadence and so
you should be somewhere between 85 and 90
beats per minute.
Meaning the left or right foot should hit
the ground 85 to 90 times per minute.
Most people don’t do that.
Most people over stride.
So by shortening the stride and quickening
the cadence the landing force is much else.
That’s why the barefoot shoes make a difference
in even some of the shorter training is that
you keep your weight over your forefoot to
your midfoot instead of heel striking.
Which gives you a much shorter stride and
a quicker turnover.
So try running uphill and see how different
it is.
In fact I teach an outdoor strength training
class, I teach a strength training class every
two weeks in Central Park, I don’t know
what time you guys get up but we do it at
6:15 in the morning.
And if anybody wants to come, please come
up here afterwards and give me your email
and we'll send you our invitation to come
try this thing.
We have about a hundred people at a time and
we do this in Central Park and it’s a lot
of fun.
We do some combination of running drill and
preventive strengthening called plyometric
which we're getting to next.
So running drill, number one, preventive strengthening,
number 2.
Stretching is way over rated.
Alright, so all of you who are spending your
whole life stretching for running way overrated.
Strengthening is way more important.
So we see a lot of people that stride out
way, way too far in their running stride and
what ends up happening is they land with all
their weight on their heel and they have these
different kinds of problems.
So this, and I may pull this out to show you,
but basically what we're doing now is much
of this functional motion screen and we're
using a lot of the great stuff you guys are
helping us develop which is, in medicine now,
taking the technology of what it looks like
to move.
And I'm gonna show you, I know you guys will
be into this so I'm going to pull this out
really quickly.
Just to show you.
I gotta get him outta the way.
I gotta close him, he's too distracting.
But just to show you what this looks like.
So we're doing a lot of more of this functional
movement.
And we can basically put markers on people
and check where they're landing, how they're
landing, where their maximum impact is and
many of our athletes that come in with these
problems are essentially over striding, so
you know you can pay some, I dunno, 150 or
200 dollars to come to our hospital and get
this done.
Or I can just tell you now, shorten your stride
and quicken your cadence and do some strength
training and you won't get hurt.
And that’s free.
So try that first before you come up here
and do that.
But that’s the concept of using technology
which I think is pretty cool to really make,
you know, movement patterns a lot healthier
and safer for people.
Which is I think really neat, and obviously
you guys are so helpful with that for us.
So as I mentioned, stretching, way over rated.
Strengthening, way underrated.
So then let's lastly talk about this functional
strength training and prevention to make you
run better and much less injuries as well.
So what I'm big into is this functional training
called plyometric training.
And plyometric training is basically using
your body weight and rapid muscle contraction
and elongation to essentially build functional
strength.
It makes people faster, it makes them hurt
less.
It reduces the reaction force between your,
basically, joints and the ground so much less
compression force, it protects your joints
and your body.
And most importantly you don’t need a fancy
gym.
You can do this anywhere.
Now, when the book came out, I did this functional
strength workout called IronStrength.
And so the way this thing is set up, is it
kind of talks about every injury and then
I have a whole section in the back called
IronStrength which is this functional strength
training workout and video.
And the video, since this is a Rodale book,
has a link up on Runner's World which free.
If you just type in Runner's World and put
in my name, or IronStrength and my name, it
will pull up and you'll see this IronStrength
workout online.
And that correlates to IronStrength workout
in the book.
And basically what that’s gonna do is teach
you how to do this functional strength training
on your own.
You just follow us along the first month,
January this was up, we had, for us it was
impressive, I know for you guys that's like
'dude, that's nothing', but we had like 1.7
million unique views which, is that?
That's pretty good isn't it?
So I get a little nod for that?
Alright, thanks.
I don’t know if that’s a lot, it seemed
like a lot to me.
So I was impressed with that, Runner's World,
I mean runners are dedicated readers, voracious
readers.
So we had a lot of people looking at that
stuff.
And this IronStrength workout is a really
helpful tool and I like it because it takes
this and makes it so that people can kind
of use on their own.
Which I think is pretty cool.
So I want you to try this thing and then come
try it live with us in Central Park.
So, lastly I'll just kinda make a couple comments
on this and answer some questions.
So the concept of this is it's kind of a full
body resource.
We did both an eBook and an iBook and the
Apple, on the iPad we have the embedded videos.
But the paperback is actually really neat
and I appreciate you guys having some people
here and I understand there's some kind of
thing that ran out but there's a way to get
more and Rich'll tell you more about that
at the end.
I did bring one signed free copy for somebody
and the question is who's gonna get the free
copy, the signed copy?
And the answer is who here has run more than
20 marathons?
Anybody?
[Pause]
[Audience giggle]
>>Male #1: Michael
>>Jordan Metzl: Michael?
Alright anybody run more than 16 marathons?
Michael, get up here, dude, you just won yourself
a free autographed book.
[Applause and hoots]
>>Jordan Metzl: Congratulations.
[Inaudible from audience]
>>Jordan Metzl: Good, if I hit it big time,
it's signed, it'll be worth something someday.
Now for those of you, and I'm giving this
to Rich this actually just came out today,
this is not related to this book topic but
it's similar concept.
In is it, I did this thing with the American
Academy of Pediatrics and it's called "Home
Based Strength Training for Young Athletes."
It's basically encouraging parents to start
strength training with their kids.
Starting at age eight and it's a high repetition
light weight training.
In kids sports we're seeing problems of a
lot of youth sports specialization and increase
in injury risk.
And so we want parents, the best trainers
are not professionals, it's parents and so
I want parents to do this with their kids.
Rich, who invited me, gets to take this home
and start.
How old's your daughter?
>>Rich: I've got three.
>>Jordan Metzl: Anybody old enough?
Good.
>>Rich: The oldest is nine.
>>Jordan Metzl: Perfect.
Alright, so the concept of kids doing strength
training is something which is, people think
is that, the answer is it's great.
It starts to build bone density, functional
strength and is a great thing to do.
So, enjoy that.
So the concept of this book is to teach you
guys how to recognize every injury you'll
get, number one.
Number two, how you can take care of it at
home on your own.
And number three, do you need to see a doctor?
And then number four, do you need surgery?
And as you know, kind of the nexus of medicine
and technology has been uniformly great.
But for example 50% of the population has
a torn meniscus, 60% of the population has
a bulging or herniated disc.
Knowing when that herniated disc or torn meniscus
is problematic and when it's not is very difficult
for somebody who's not in medicine to know.
And so, what I really want to do is educate
my athletic patients and athletic minded people
of how you can make the make best decisions
for yourselves.
Because Dr. Google, I'm sorry, gives a lot
of information.
Some of it's great, some of it's not so great.
But a lot of it's out there.
And so you guys do such a great job supplying
information, but it's a lot of information.
And helping people kind of disseminate what
is helpful I think is very important for people.
So with that, I would say please register
for my site so you can stay in touch if you
want.
And I'd love to answer any questions about
these topics or your own running related issues
or just sports in general or anything about
the quality of life, health, and happiness.
Who's got some questions for me?
Don’t be shy about your own injuries.
Yeah?
>>Male #2: [inaudible] shoulder injury for
strength training-
>>Jordan Metzl: Oh I'm sorry; you gotta go
to the mic so we can hear.
[Unintelligible]
>>Male #2: For like a shoulder injury, doing
strength training.
What is the, what's the general guideline?
Is it, this doesn't seem like to be like,
this never really fully goes away.
So when do you start pushing again?
>>Jordan Metzl: So some general concepts and
what I'm after in this kind of book and video
is a lot about what is called functional training.
What does that mean?
What it means is, if I just do bicep curls,
I'm just strengthening my bicep, right?
Or leg extensions on a leg extension machine,
I'm just strengthening my quad.
And you know, for a long time people did that
kind of training and many do at a number of
gyms around the area.
But the problem is it's not very helpful nor
very efficient and it seems to kind of not
do much in terms of what's called functional.
And so functional training is doing, like
in our video we have multiple body motions
at the same time with high repetition, light
weight training.
And so it's not like you're doing big weights
but it's higher repetitions of a light weight
which, over time, builds almost equivalent
strength.
And so the answer to a shoulder injury, you
know, depending on what is, is that kind of
get rid of the irritant in the shoulder.
So sometimes we do injections of a little
steroid into a bursa or whatever the problem
is.
And then do this functional training around
the joint.
And it's high repetition and light weight
training which almost counter intuitive to
the way people think about training.
And it really seems to change that kinda way
that people do it.
So you can effectively train, and in the shoulder,
particularly, is very amenable, the strength
around it.
And just knowing what to do should help a
lot.
So give it a try and let me know.
>>Male #3: Yeah, I'm curious about recuperation
from particularly like long distance running
or specific workout.
So, in particular ice, the use of ice and
ibuprofen.
>>Jordan Metzl: Sure.
So basically inflammation is both a good thing
and a bad thing.
So inflammation is helpful when something
gets irritated or inflamed, its very helpful
for us.
Cause it kinda, it's a body marker, hey, we
got a problem here.
When somebody does something, so there's helpful
and hurtful inflammation.
So an Achilles tendon, you go out for a long
run, you get some Achilles tendinitis.
Over time if that goes on and on it can actually
start to, like a cavity, start to wear down
that tendon and you get tendinosis and then
a chronic partial tear.
So you get a whole kind of host of problems
that happens over time if something's just
chronically irritated.
So there's chronic inflammation and there's
kinda something after doing a particular event.
And the answer is that you know, we love the
George Costanza special.
Which is getting in an ice bath, which is
a very helpful way to get in something cold
for you know, if you can make it 5 minutes
in an ice bath.
And much like boiling a frog, though I've
never done it, but what they say if you're
going to boil a frog, which hopefully nobody
here or in California has ever done, is if
you just put the frog in water it jumps right
out but if you put the frog in and gradually
turn up the heat, it stays in there.
I don’t know if that's true or not but that's
the story.
And so with cold water and ice baths it's
the same thing.
Get in there and start dumping some ice in
and over time as the temperature lowers, supposedly,
and I do know this, it's actually much more
able to tolerate that.
So I think for post-run recovery, nothing,
anything over and hour and half, nothing beats
an ice bath.
So getting into a cold bath will definitely
help expedite your recovery as well as getting
a carb and fat something in your body within
a half hour.
That's called the Golden Half Hour after a
big work out.
So don't wait two hours, take a nap and then
go eat.
You basically start to, your turnaround will
get quicker if you refuel that muscle glycogen
within a half hour of your exercise.
So those are the things: ice and getting that
fuel in right away are the two really helpful
things.
>>Male #3: Are you against ibuprofen in general?
>>Jordan Metzl: I'm not at all, I think basically
for longer stuff I guess there's what I do
and what I say.
What I say is, you know, probably not a great
idea for big doses for sure.
If you wanna pop one here or there before
you do stuff I think that's probably OK The
problem with ibuprofen and you know, much,
you know many of these are sold over the counter,
is they think alright, well it's like Advil,
it's candy coated, I can just take that, but
these are drugs.
And if you take enough of those, you can cause
a real problem.
So a little bit here and there I don’t think
is usually problematic, you know a lot can
be a big issue.
But they can certainly cause ulcers, too.
So you have to be careful not to do any lots
of that stuff on an empty stomach.
>>Male #3: Thanks.
>>Jordan Metzl: Sure.
>>Male #4: So, you and everybody else says
walking is a great regular way to stay in
shape without having to put a phenomenal amount
of effort in.
I don't like walking, I like bicycling, is
that just as good?
>>Jordan Metzl: So, that's a great question
and the answer is that I generally find people
are the most compliant with their exercise
prescription if they like what they're doing.
And so if they feel like I have to run cause
this guy told me I have to walk around but
I hate it, I love biking then they're gonna
not do it and nothing, anything is better
than nothing.
In the relative scale of expenditure, you
know hard running is the most time effective
per whatever you can do.
A hard run.
But if you're like hating every step and you're
not pushing yourself, it's terrible for you.
So if you can get your, it's all about getting
your heart rate up.
And if you can push your cardiovascular threshold
and really get your heart rate up and move,
by biking, then that's terrific and there
are a number of places to do that.
So if you like and you'll do it, that’s
a great way.
And I do think the merits of group exercise,
like spinning particularly, are very helpful
and people will push themselves a lot harder
if there's a group around.
So you know, getting, that's why our strength
training class is so much fun, is cause everybody
basically kicks each other's butt.
Which is helpful, really makes it work a lot
better.
So if you can find that dynamic in a spin
class or even a bike thing, you'll get much
more cardiovascular out of that.
>> Male #5: Hi, thanks for coming out today.
>>Jordan Metzl: Sure.
>> Male #5: Well you know, IT band.
Just, it is what it is but, to make that a
general thing, are there any pains that you
would say are OK to push through?
Or any time you have a pain should you just
stop when it occurs.
>>Jordan Metzl: Two good questions and I'll
answer the second part first.
And so the pain issue is when your IT band
pain is changing your running mechanic, then
it's time to stop.
If it's a little bit achy here and there,
I don’t worry about it.
So my telltale thing is if pain changes your
mechanic of movement is number one.
Now IT band is basically a muscle called the
tensor fasciae latae muscle that runs on the
outside part of your hip across your hip joint
and your knee joint.
And the typical person with IT band syndrome
is somebody that comes in saying "I'm running
about, you know, two, three miles or a mile
and about 10-15 minutes in I feel like somebody's
jabbing something into the side of my leg"
and that's typically classic IT band syndrome.
And the answer is number one, flexibility.
So I have a whole thing in this IronStrength
workout section called the Foam Roller Workout
and anybody friends with a foam roller?
Several of you, good.
And so the foam roller is a great at home
deep tissue massages that you can do pretty
much every day to loosen up the muscle, the
IT band along the outside part of the leg.
The second part, then, is building this functional
strength.
And in the book in our IT band section we
have what's call the Big Butt Bonus.
And it doesn't mean your butt's gonna get
big, so don't worry.
But it means your butt's gonna get strong.
And in the Big Butt Bonus section we have
all these glute strengthening exercises to
basically keep your pelvis stable.
The video I didn't show you of this woman
stepping down off the box, you know she was
somebody who had a lot of IT band problems
and as she was kinda running, her hip was
dropping on the hurt side and her pelvis was
unstable when she was running.
And that caused some chronic IT band problems
over time.
So strengthening is hugely important.
And the final thing is, there's a little fluid
filled sac called a bursa, which can form
between the tendon and the bone and sometimes
we have to give a little shot of cortisone
in that IT band, just in that bursa.
But again, if you don’t fix the mechanical
factors, it'll just keep happening.
So, IT band is very fixable, it's very frustrating
for a lot of runners but very fixable with
the right stuff.
>> Male #5: Thanks.
>>Jordan Metzl: Sure.
>>Female #1: Hi, what about an injury or a
pain that is there only when you rest, not
when you actually exercise?
>>Jordan Metzl: That's easy, keep moving.
That's the –
[Audience laughter]
>>Jordan Metzl: [laughs] Umm
>>Female #1: Yeah but like an acute pain,
you know the sciatic?
>>Jordan Metzl: So it's not uncommon actually,
people go out, they work out and they get
some pains afterwards.
And so, it sounds like sciatic type pain,
here's my guess.
When you're sitting on it, it hurts the most?
>>Female #1: Yeah.
>>Jordan Metzl: OK, gotcha.
So pain in the butt, yeah?
>>Female #1: Yeah.
[Giggle]
>>Jordan Metzl: OK, so what's happening is
that the sciatic nerve, in the hip/glut section
we have two kinds of sciatic pain.
Sciatic pain can come out of the back and
what happens is you get a bulging disc in
your back which pushes in nerve and shoots
pain down your leg.
And those hurt all the time.
Or you can get the sciatic nerve running through
the butt muscle and the butt muscle, called
the piriformis muscle, will squeeze that nerve
after you've worked out.
And basically just shoot this pain down the
back of your leg, especially when you're sitting
on it.
And again, a little bit of anti-inflammatory
medicine can make that feel better but the
key is building, sorry, but building a stronger
butt.
And the stronger your butt muscle gets, the
less that muscle will want to squeeze on that
nerve.
And so, you need a stronger butt, and that's
the answer.
And then the last thing is I have a whole
bunch of stuff in there on some different
stretching, the Figure Four stretch is helpful.
That's where one case where flexibility can
make a difference to loosen it up.
But to really fix it you gotta start, those
plyometric jump squats, you will first hate
them, but one you learn to love them it will
make this go away, I promise.
>>Female Audience Member #1: OK, thank you.
>> Male #6: I'm asking on behalf of my wife
who's a cardio junkie.
Who can probably do with some rest, because
she's worked herself into a really bad back
situation.
So what are some of the exercises you can
recommend for somebody who really thrives
on the adrenaline, thrives on the sweat, thrives
on the cardio but needs to back off a little
bit.
>>Jordan Metzl: Alright, so we've got a wife
at home, my wife, but says the wife at home,
alright fair enough.
So the wife at home who's the cardio junkie
and I will say just by way of this, that yes
there are junkies of exercise.
Exercise junkies is a real thing but as I
always say, I'd rather somebody be addicted
to exercising than anything.
So be proud of your wife, but that being said
you know she's not doing enough functional
training and so the cool thing about this
IronStrength workout is, I promise you, you're
gonna go home, you're gonna earn a lot of
brownie points at home here.
Cause you're go home and say we're gonna try
this together.
And I promise you that when she gets through
her like fourth set of burpees, she's gonna
be having more cardio than she ever had doing
the other stuff.
So the nice thing about this is it's both
cardio and functional strength as well.
But I generally find people who only do one
set of thing without that kind of cross training
built in, get hurt all the time.
And so this concept of total rest days, I
really don't buy that so much.
I think you can do less and more and different
kinds of stuff.
But I think the concept of functional training
interspersed with cardio is so helpful.
So I think, try this and let me know.
She will thank you and it's a huge work out.
This'll be as much a workout as running.
>> Male #6: It's in the book?
>>Jordan Metzl: Well the pictures are in the
book and the workout's online.
That’s that IronStrength on Runner's World.
Alright?
>> Male #7: Hi, thanks for the book.
My biggest problem with marathons is in the
closing, you know, last three or four miles,
hamstring cramps.
I don't know what it is that I'm doing wrong.
I've done a lot of marathons, I've had some
success but I can't seem to fend that off.
>>Jordan Metzl: Gotcha.
So muscle cramping happens for basically for
two main reasons.
So I'll talk about both.
Less commonly but sometimes related to muscle
cramping is actually strength.
So people aren't strong enough, so I think
some of this functional training that I've
been talking about will definitely help with
some people.
But actually, surprisingly, more commonly
for muscle cramping that's nutritional.
And when people think about nutrition and
muscle cramping people think alright I've
gotta eat bananas because I'm getting muscle,
who here has had bananas for muscle cramping?
Everybody got force fed bananas.
And the answer is the potassium is BS, that
basically we don’t have a lot of data, we
have a lot of data on sodium.
And salt is the culprit for most people with
muscle cramping.
And so what I'm gonna have you do, basically
what's happening over time, I'm betting in
your marathons, is you're not salt loading
enough and you're not pre-salt loading and
when you get that lower salt sodium hyponatremia
the first symptom is muscle cramping.
So my bet is that you're what we call a salty
sweater.
Everybody in this room sweats a different
amount and different concentration of sodium.
And if you're a salty sweater you know it
cause when you're done with a long run you
kinda look like you should be like a human
deer lick or something.
You've got that white stuff all over, not
a good look.
So you're a salty sweater, so if you are you
need to basically give yourself more salt
along the course, and so there, you know everything
from pretzels to there are these little salt
caps and I want you to try some of those and
I bet you that with some strengthening and
with the sodium, it's one of those two things,
I'm betting.
And you can try an experiment and see, that
if it's late in the race usually it's just
that you're losing too much salt and you have
not kind of built up.
You can actually pre-salt load the day before
in addition to your pasta, some extra salt
and then during your exercise more than an
hour and half, start putting some more salt
into what you do.
And then some races have, Gatorade makes a
great product called Endurance Formula Gatorade,
it's double sodium.
And that has double salt and that will help
a lot in terms of sodium.
So try some more salt and I bet that makes
a big difference.
>> Male #7: Cool, thank you.
Do you recommend salt caplets or just a standard
salt packet?
>>Jordan Metzl: The salt packets don't work
cause when you get sweaty it just kind of
disintegrates so they make, a number of companies
make these little, there's one called Saltstick,
there's one called Endurolyte and these kind
of sodium containing capsules and you just
carry those along and pop one or two of those
and I bet you'll notice.
And you can kind, try and think like when
it's hot and humid am I getting this more?
Is it happening I'm cold, cause cold cramping
tends to be strength.
The hot humid cramping tends to be sodium.
>> Male Audience Member #7: OK thanks.
>>Jordan Metzl: Alright?
Sure.
>> Male #8: Hi, this is a follow up on the
potassium.
I notice that a lot of people, a lot of my
friends who play sports basketball, football
they started drinking a lot of coconut water,
coconut juice and I just want hear your take
on that?
And then more generally, after you do like
the functional training, the plyometric jumps,
the burpees whatever, what's your best thing
to take in terms of recovery aside from eating
right after?
Like amino acids, protein etcetera.
>>Jordan Metzl: Alright two good questions.
So first with the coconut water craze.
I mean I think coconut water is great it's
basically isotonic so it's kinda not high
sodium, it's kinda neutral.
I think eating is fine, coconut water is fine
if you like and you're gonna take it.
It's probably a little more nutrient rich
than obviously water which has essentially
none.
But it's not like a magic formula.
So people are always looking, oh I need this,
it's not a this.
Just food is fine, too.
But if you like that there's no down side.
And if you're gonna take it, it tastes good,
no problems.
It's a little expensive but no big deal.
In terms of post-injury, post-workout foods,
fuels.
I really don’t like the kinda powders and
all that.
I know there is a whole big industry of these
synthetic powders but I just think anything
that has like a half-life of six years on
the shelf is probably not a good idea.
And so I think just natural, natural occurring
foods.
I mean get stuff that's on the perimeter of
the supermarket.
Anything that's in the middle that doesn’t
expire until 2016, you know, stay away from
I think in general.
And it doesn't matter, it's totally you know
much like the guy asked about biking, it's
whatever you will take is fine for me.
That it can be scrambled eggs, it can be you
know yogurt, blueberries and granola.
Whatever it is that you like, do it.
And there's no magic answer to that, basically
naturally occurring food I think is the best.
Some combination of carbs and protein, scrambled
eggs is great.
Anything you'll do is great.
Alright, no magic answer.
>> Male #9: Hi I'm trying to get back into
a more aggressive athletic routine and a bunch
of chronic injuries are sort of resurfacing.
Do you recommend from a medical standpoint,
establishing a baseline whether it is trying
to figure out whether it’s a meniscus or
a ligament or you know, whatever the joints
are.
I mean, is a baseline something to seek medical
help with to then figure out if it's getting
better or worse?
>>Jordan Metzl: That's a good question, I
mean the answer to that is that I would start
doing stuff and start building some strength
and see if there's a one pinpoint thing that's
the exact thing every time.
If just kind of everything hurts cause you're
doing more, that tends to be kind of functional
except if there's one thing that's actively
limiting your ability to be active then I
would get that thing checked out.
But I'm sure you have a meniscus tear, I'm
sure you do-
>> Male #9: Yeah.
>>Jordan Metzl: -just because many people
do.
So and if we get an MRI it'll show up and
what happens is people get surgery all the
time because they have a meniscus tear on
their MRI and they're no better and they've
had a piece of their meniscus taken out and
they're actually worse off.
And so you know I think the key is to start
doing some of the stuff I'm talking about,
see how it goes, see what happens to that
pain.
If there's one particular thing that's problematic,
then we can look at that further.
>> Male Audience Member #9: OK
>>Jordan Metzl: Alright?
>> Male #10: Hey Jordan, thanks for coming
in.
>>Jordan Metzl: No prob.
>> Male #10: I try to bike at least every
day to work to and fro and I have lower back
pains.
What do you suggest doing?
Stretching before or after or both?
>>Jordan Metzl: Good question.
So you know, how far are you biking and where
are you coming from?
>> Male #10: I do about six or eight miles
each way.
>>Jordan Metzl: Oh nice, and you're coming
from where abouts?
>> Male #10: Brooklyn.
>>Jordan Metzl: So coming over the bridge
and stuff.
So you know number one is back pain from biking
can be a couple things.
Number one if you're doing serious biking
like this guy maybe, bike racing or stuff,
bike fit is very undervalued for you know,
making your bike comfortable.
If it's kinda commuter biking and you're going
back and forth which is a great way to get
around and I think getting around New York
on bike is, I'm really excited for the bike
sharing program which is gonna start in July
here.
Which is gonna be, anyway you guys probably
know about this stuff but it's gonna be terrific.
>> Male #10: Great.
>>Jordan Metzl: And I think that, you know
I have a whole bunch of stuff in the book
on what's called core strengthening, isometric
planks.
To build up what are the core muscles around
your middle.
And most often bikers don't do enough middle
strengthening and so you kinda end up like
an Oreo.
You kinda have this soft inside so you gotta
start strengthening the middle.
Those core muscles support you when you're
sitting on your bike seat and it makes that
pain go away.
So start some of the core blaster exercises
I have, some of the core strengthening and
you can do it at home.
Try you know a few times a week and I bet
your back feels a ton better from that.
>> Male Audience Member #10: OK, quick question.
Post long bike, chocolate milk or coconut
juice?
>>Jordan Metzl: Take one of each.
I mean, chocolate milk's got -
>> Male #10: That's a bad combination.
[Audience laughter]
>>Jordan Metzl: Yeah it probably is.
I personally, chocolate milk is probably better
cause it's a got a little more fat content
and a little more carb content.
So I think maybe during long ride coconut
water and post long ride I'd go with chocolate
milk.
>> Male Audience Member #10: OK, thanks.
>>Jordan Metzl: Sure.
Last question.
>> Male #11: Hi, I don't remember if the book
addresses this in detail, I read it a while
ago.
Any tips for running heat?
Because summer is much nastier here in New
York rather than California.
>>Jordan Metzl: Yeah, so you know running
in New York City in the heat is a real issue.
I mean, California is lucky in that sense
but you know, the biggest problem I see if
you're running in the heat is acclimatization.
So I have many fewer problems with people
running in the heat in August than I do in
June when we get a hot day when it's been
kinda cool.
So the body takes about a week to ten days
to acclimatize to heat.
And so when it gradually builds up over time,
like it is now here, you know, you need a
little more hydration, you probably need a
little more salt.
You need to kind of pre-hydrate.
You have some of these more common muscle
cramping issues.
But in general your body gets to, it acclimatizes
to heat over time.
The problem is if you're up here and you say
listen I'm gonna go for a getaway to Miami
and it's kinda 45 here and it's 80 there,
and you get off the plane and go for a 10
mile run.
Those are the people that end up with a lot
of kinda of more significant.
If you go run the Miami half marathon, that
weekend I always see people the next couple
days with bad muscle tears because they've
just been running in the cool and they're
not acclimatized.
So heat tends to be the problem with acclimatization
and then you know, some of the sodium and
some of the dehydration stuff as well.
>> Male #11: Thanks.
>>Jordan Metzl: Alright, so I just wanna say
in conclusion thank you guys so much, a pleasure
to be here.
I know I was competing against Justin Beiber
on Friday, but you learned some good stuff
here.
So I really appreciate being here, thanks
a lot.
Bye-bye.
[applause]